playstation fires back at microsoft's
claims regarding call of duty
exclusivity the xbox ui is getting an
overhaul new battlefield games and more
on today's gamespot news
mom and dad are fighting playstation
boss jim ryan has responded to microsoft
gaming ceo phil spencer who said his
company would go above and beyond
industry standards and keep call of duty
on playstation for years to come if the
xbox company's acquisition of activision
blizzard goes through ryan told game
industry biz that microsoft offered to
keep call of duty on playstation for
specifically three years after the
existing deal between activision and
sony finishes ryan said this was quote
inadequate on many levels quote
microsoft has only offered for call of
duty to remain on playstation for three
years after the current agreement
between activision and sony ends ryan
said quote after almost 20 years of call
of duty on playstation their proposal
was inadequate on many levels and fail
to take account of the impact on our
gamers we want to guarantee playstation
games continue to have the highest
quality call of duty experience and
microsoft's proposal undermines this
principle we don't know however what the
duration of the previously agreed upon
deal between sony and activision for
call of duty was but whatever that is
it'll be extended by three years
apparently but what happens after that
is unclear microsoft's deal to buy
activision blizzard is currently being
reviewed by regulatory bodies around the
world new zealand will be among the next
countries to weigh in with the decision
due by september 9th speaking of
microsoft the company is looking to give
the xbox ui a makeover with a number of
changes planned that will roll out as
experiments for xbox insiders over the
next few months a key new feature is a
planned jump back in row which is
designed to give players quick access to
their most recently played games and
apps system apps like settings store
search and my games and apps will be
easier to access as they will have their
own tiles on xbox home microsoft notes
that the rollout will be slow to start
and that xbox will be iterating
throughout the process but a full launch
of the new ui is planned for sometime in
2023 while xbox and playstation bicker
over call of duty battlefield has been
making some moves marcus lato who
designed master chief and co-created the
halo universe is heading up a brand new
battlefield studio in seattle electronic
arts announced that the studio is called
ridgeline games and it will develop a
quote narrative campaign for battlefield
very little is known right now but ea
said this campaign will quote engage
fans in new and exciting ways while
remaining true to the classic elements
of the series another big announcement
was that battlefield creative director
lars gustavsson who has worked on the
battlefield series since it starts in
2002 is departing the team with these
announcements ea reiterated that it
wants fans to know that ea is quote all
in on battlefield the company has dice
continuing to work on battlefield's
multiplayer suite while another studio
ripple effect will create and quote
entirely new battlefield experience that
will complement and build upon the
series foundations another company that
recently suffered from a rocket launch
is cd project red that confirmed in its
latest earnings call that it's committed
to releasing its current gen port of the
witcher 3 the wild hunt by the end of
the year ps5 and xbox series x and s
editions of the game have been delayed a
number of times originally intended for
release in 2021 and then for earlier in
2022. the q4 release window means the
game should be out between october and
december this year with cd projekt
likely to be aiming for a release in
time for the holidays the release will
be a complete edition of witcher 3
including all its expansions with all
content enhanced for next-gen consoles
the ps5 and xbox series xs versions of
the game will also come with all new
free dlcs inspired by the witcher
netflix series
and that's it for today's gamespot news
are you excited by these battlefield
announcements will you be picking up the
witcher 3 on next gem when it comes out
hopefully this year let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you
tomorrow for more gamespot news
[Music]